[Music]
today's question comes from trevor in
california i'm 28 years old single on
baby step four and earn 400 000 a year
how do i leave the golden handcuffs of a
lucrative career in tech sales to
transition to a career in luxury excuse
me luxury residential real estate this
is my true passion but i have no idea
where to start
well he's making really really good
money but dave the challenge with moving
uh into
real estate whether it's luxury or
luxury i don't know why i'm struggling
with that word or regular uh holmes if
you will is you can't do it part time
i've talked a lot of experts i don't
know if you defer on that opinion but
you kind of at some point have to go all
in uh in real estate sales now he's
making a lot of good money so he could
save a good chunk and kind of pad his
stats if you will so that when he goes
to luxury real estate he's all in and
he's not really hurting for money but
that's a save and then get qualified
and then dive in
but i i don't know i you know luxury
real estate's a whole different ball
game very exclusive you know more about
that than than i do as far as how unique
that particular side of real estate
sales is yeah i mean it you don't just
dive into that do you
you know you can work your way up you
can you've got you don't have to start
selling cheap houses to sell expensive
houses but you've got you've got to have
some
knowledge of that marketplace and
knowledge of dealing with that type of
clientele
so what i would do
um is i would join a luxury real estate
team
part-time yeah and get your get your
license under you get your you know get
some of the prereqs the legal prereqs
behind you
get out there be moving around do some
transactions on a part-time basis
because the good news about residential
real estate is you generally work for a
situation like this it's not it's not
good news overall but good news you
generally work when others don't
because people can't look at a house
during the day even luxury sometimes
they can if they're you know they're
transferring whatever but i mean they're
gonna look at houses at nights and
weekends
and so
the exception of somebody coming in from
out of town or whatever that kind of
thing but uh you know you can you can
use some of your pto you can do some
other stuff work around and uh you know
just work a 40-hour week is all at your
current position
and take your nights and weekends and
the occasional vacation time and you
know take six months and
get up on the on-ramp a little smoother
rather than just jumping off the high
dive and hoping there's water in the
pool that's exactly right yeah yeah and
then but but it is going to end up being
where you have you're probably not going
to get the boat as close to the dock as
i would like correct meaning your luxury
real estate income up to close enough to
your tech before you make the jump
you're probably going to have to do the
thing you're talking about there's a
little bit of a step of faith there but
just going cold turkey it takes six
months three months just to get up and
moving that's correct and you can do all
of that on a part-time basis much more
efficiently and not lose that chunk of
income that's correct while you're doing
that but yeah i think you make the
transition i it's
it's a weird time to do it uh the good
thing about the real estate market
slowing down is
all these people that just went and got
the real estate license because real
estate was easy yeah they're gonna fall
off they're the first ones to leave last
in first out
and so uh it it it calls out the
under producers it calls out a hard time
a recession
a slower real estate market calls out
the agents that are not rock stars that
are not the best of the best and so
because you got to pay
to keep
the licenses the re you know the realtor
fees the mls fees all that stuff it
costs if you don't if you're not making
money in the business it's not something
you can just park it and sit there
uh so it does it really does push people
out of the business in times like this
so it is a good time to make this
transition
versus trying to jump in while
everybody's riding these wave it's like
you know lately has been like going
surfing in the middle of a hurricane
i mean it's just there's a lot of waves